lundi 14 mars quatre jours après le
tremblement de terre
il est 17h45 et les 120 secouristes de
la sécurité civile française viennent
d'atterrir sur l'aéroport d'haneda à
tokyo la radioactivité
il ya une inquiétude légitime de garçons
qui ont regardé les médias avant de
partir en opération mais mais elle est
une inquiétude atténuée parce que ces
agents formés travailler en ambiance
chimiques radiologiques donc ils seront
gérés
mais songez s'il y avait un besoin je
crois pas je crois que je crois qu'on va
travailler sur du sauvetage est vraiment
classique classique la situation ne
l'est pas mais le lieutenant-colonel ne
le sait pas encore
[Musique]
l'ambassadeur de france au japon
philippe faure est venu lui-même
accueillir les secouristes sur le tarmac
des premiers vrais fing on va voir sur
une carte avant midi
c'est bien sondheim automne elle se
trouve donc environ ce à peu près 50 km
m des deux amis tout ça ici un voilà à
côté de l'aéroport
ça c'est un endroit qui était très
ravagé le pire de tous les
ressortissants français loue tout le
localisation préférentielle à bourgneuf
quatre jours après le séisme
l'ambassadeur est encore sous le choc
c'est terrorisant main cicero d'autant
plus terrorisant que sa durée
ça a duré près de trois minutes hein je
crois 2045 2050 sous la table et que ça
bouge fortement tous super bien sûr dans
les prochains jours une de nos équipes
va suivre ces hommes de la sécurité
civile qui pensent encore à ce moment là
pour voir sauver des vies
[Musique]
dans ce même aéroport une autre de nos
équipes va tenter de se rendre par ses
propres moyens sur les zones sinistrées
mais les téléviseurs de l'aéroport
international viennent d'annoncer
l'explosion du réacteur numéro 3 de la
centrale nucléaire de fukushima la
traductrice qui doit nous accompagner
mao s'interroge l'un des bâtiments
derrière le réacteur était intacte à
niveau et à 4 heures de l'après midi il
ne restait plus que les vous avez peur
oui tout le monde est terrifié et vous
allez nous accompagner quand même non je
suis désolé c'est la raison pour
laquelle je ne peux pas vous accompagner
j'ai peur pour ma vie
notre reporter décide de partir seul
il va prendre un vol intérieur pour
rejoindre le nord du pays
la sécurité civile par en convoi vers le
nord elle emprunte une autoroute
désormais réservé aux secours
les français sont parmi les tout
premiers à rejoindre la zone
la population ne peut plus prendre cette
route vers le nord non
c'est fermé les seuls qui peuvent passer
sur les secours et les officiels mais
civile n'ont pas les civils les civils
un an devant nos yeux les premières
traces du passage du tsunami des champs
inondés à perte de vue des deux côtés de
l'autoroute déserte
nous allons parcourir 300 km pour
atteindre l'une des zones les plus
sévèrement touchés aux sushis au toucher
pendant ce temps notre deuxième équipe a
rejoint le nord
son objectif otsuchi une petite ville
dont 85% des habitants sont portés
disparus
non n'y allez pas toutes les routes sont
coupées vous n'y arriverez jamais par là
le policier a dit vrai il nous faudra
faire toute une série de détours et nous
mettrons plus de six heures pour
parcourir 80 km
les premières traces de la catastrophe
apparaissent
ce panneau arraché nous indique que nous
sommes arrivés à destination
otsuchi
[Musique]
de cette petite ville de 17000 habitants
il ne reste que cette route comme une
digue qui a résisté miraculeusement
de part et d'autre la ville a été rasée
en outils
balayés
[Musique]
sur les décombres pas de secouriste pas
de renforts militaires personnes
[Musique]
le seul endroit où il y est encore de la
vie c'est la route parcourue de rescapés
m
[Musique]
tous ont l'air abattu
certains se racontent leur infortune
quand tu vois mon ami là et vient à sa
maison tu vois la rouge qui est là-bas
la rouge la wii bien avant elle était de
l'autre côté du pont si loin que ça
c'est vrai j'habitais là à côté du
cabinet médical
en dehors de ce bref échange le silence
est impressionnant troublé uniquement
par le passage d'un hélicoptère
nous rencontrons un japonais qui parlent
quelques mots d'anglais ils acceptent de
ne servir de guide
bon je vais vous aider mais pas
maintenant je vais revenir
je vais revenir vous cherchez dans
l'immédiat il a d'autres urgences mais
il nous donne rendez-vous dans quelques
heures
après huit heures de route le convoi de
la sécurité civile atteint enfin sandaï
avec un million d'habitants c'est la
plus grosse agglomération touchées par
le tsunami
c'est ici que les autorités japonaises
ont fixé rendez vous à trois équipes de
secouristes venues de l'étranger
je pense qu'il répartition des zones
attribuées sur des secteurs alors les
transfère par là et les interprètes par
ici malgré l'ampleur de la catastrophe
le sens de l'organisation à la japonaise
est intacte maintenant le responsable de
la municipalité va vous expliquer la
situation
merci beaucoup
votre mission est de vous rendront dans
le quartier de yuya gay il va falloir
dégager le quartier nettoyer les débris
des maisons emportées par le tsunami
est-ce qu'il est encore possible de
trouver des survivants
oui il ya de l'espoir
et on continue à chercher encore mais je
vous mets en garde
il y encore un risque de répliques et de
tsunami on essaiera de vous avertir mais
même si vous n'entendiez pas
d'avertissement soyez prêts à vous
réfugier sur les hauteurs en cas de
besoin en ce moment même il y un
incendie à la centrale nucléaire
selon nos informations d'hier il ne
devrait pas y avoir de danger
taiwan ait ordonné retour dans le nord
avec les rescapés d'otsuchi
la nuit tombe nous allons retrouver
l'homme qui va nous servir d'interprète
devant le collège où il travaille il est
professeur d'anglais
ce bâtiment est devenu le dernier
endroit habitable à des kilomètres à la
ronde
les gens qui sont ici ont perdu leur
famille ils ont perdu leur maison ils
sont choqués ils viennent ici pour
trouver un abri et quelque chose à
manger
ils sont choqués ils sont nerveux
on ne peut pas aller leur poser de
questions parce qu'ils sont sous le choc
ils sont en larmes
vous comprenez
ce que
basra journée
ok ici j'ai un abri je suis au chaud on
va se débrouiller
mais pas un bâtiment c
[Musique]
elle a perdu sa maison sa maison a été
inondée et emportés par la mer mais elle
dit que pour l'avenir
elle garde le moral il faut que nous
survivions dans ce que tu sais ce
qu'elle détient il faut survivre
ne pas se lamenter défendre la dignité
des siens l'homme ne nous laissera
entrer dans le bâtiment que pour
quelques minutes
ici ils sont plus d'une centaine ce qui
nous frappe c'est le calme le silence
un îlot de paix au milieu du chaos
[Musique]
où
l'homme nous demandent de ressortir
dehors le sait mieux filmé à l'extérieur
plus tôt
[Musique]
dans cette ville où il n'y a ni
électricité ni chauffage et où la
température descend la nuit en dessous
de zéro on se réchauffent autour d'un
feu de bois en montrant les images qui
reste de sa vie d'avant ma maison est
hélas ma maison était ici
et je n'ai retrouvé que le dernier étage
non
notre poule est grave
plus au sud à sendai dans leurs
campements improvisés les hommes de la
sécurité civile se réveille hier ils ont
atteint la ville à la tombée de la nuit
trop tard pour commencer les opérations
de recherche ils s'apprêtent à faire
leurs premiers pas sur le terrain à 100
km de là l'état de la centrale nucléaire
de fukushima inquiète mais la sécurité
civile à emporter de quoi mesurer
l'exposition radiation de chacun de ses
hommes n'avaient nous ramener à 5,9 au
cder on est prêt à l'armee l'attention
des gens c'est ça c'est le sait leur
usage ça c'est ça c'est la larme qu'ici
je suis en fait t'es invite donc voir
qu'après ce qui n'est pas énorme du
doubs donc c
l'ensemble de la du dispositif
l'ensemble des personnels dispose d'un
dosimètre individuel de ce type là qui
nous permet en instantané de mesurer la
dose de radioactivité qu'on reçoit et
sans des appareils qui sont
électroniquement très sophistiqués qui
permettent de comparer la dose que l'on
reçoit au corps humain est donc de
savoir exactement les effets de la
radioactivité sur le corps humain donc
en fonction de cet appareil on sait si
on est en sécurité ou pas de sueur sur
le plan vraiment physiologique et et
humain des dégâts liés à la
radioactivité dans les camions 20 tonnes
de matériel à porter depuis la france
des systèmes capables de détecter des
survivants sous les décombres des vérins
pour soulever les débris qui retiendrait
des blessés les secouristes ne le savent
pas encore mais ce matériel ne leur sera
d'aucune utilité
les équipes de la sécurité civile arrive
enfin sur le périmètre qui leur a été
assignée
[Musique]
nous découvrons un paysage tout
simplement un peu khalip tic
[Musique]
ioulia guettaient une commune de 7000
habitants voisine de sendai
situé en bord de mer sur un terrain sans
relief elle a été entièrement englouti
par une vague de dix mètres de haut
dans cette partie de la ville l'habitat
était essentiellement constitué de
petits pavillons de bois il n'en reste
que des planches s'éparpiller
comment oui effectivement c'est
impressionnant on est des hommes avant
d'être des sapeurs sauveteurs
effectivement ses fonctions mais là je
mets mais je dirais mais mes émotions
personnelles de côté à la ronde a engagé
une course contre le temps
la priorité maintenant est d'engager le
travail le plus vite possible pour
retrouver des victimes potentielles
la neige a commencé à tomber il faisait
zéro degré les équipes du lieutenant
colonel valette vont rapidement se
rendre compte que la recherche de
survivants est un objectif illusoire sa
présentation
cette voiture est en équilibre précaire
au dessus d'un petit étang le givre ans
les vitres opaques
il faut les briser pour voir s'il ya
quelqu'un à l'intérieur
enfin un bâton de sup est une nuise pour
toi
vide
on note personne dans la voiture
aucun blessé détecté dans les décombres
pas un survivant seulement des cadavres
une marque de peinture à chaque fois
qu'un corps sans vie et retrouver comme
ici sous cette poutre pour l'instant
donc un paysage on va dire à serge
lasserre galipes sic des maisons des
maisons un petit peu partout
qui en subit quand même pas mal de
dégâts des décombres des décombres
vraiment de partout essentiellement
composée de bois est pour l'instant
de manière très visuelle donc une
personne une personne décédée voilà pour
pour le reste pour l'instant donc on a
on a on a donc un chien et un maître
chien qui ont fait quelques marquage sur
des postures des potentiels aux odeurs
néanmoins points sans nous n'avons nous
n'avons pas pu confirmer que ces odeurs
correspondait à des cadors ya une chance
encore à décor comme ça en bout dans un
acteur comme ça c'est pas évident mais
ça ils la chance existe toujours
voilà on va se fier à ça et comme on dit
l'espoir fait vivre donc dans une
manière on va continuer à chercher
après après si on s'en tient des des
conditions climatiques
effectivement elles sont pas optimum que
qu'une personne puisse résister à de
telles températures en étant depuis si
longtemps sous des décombres d'une part
d'autre part d'un point de vue
complètement médicale ce qu'on a
l'habitude de voir c'est que certains et
certaines personnes peuvent tenir
jusqu'à sept jours
mais l'espoir doit parfois reconnaître
sa défaite après sept heures de
recherche les hommes de la sécurité
civile ne retrouveront que des morts
les milliers de disparus que compte la
région se trouve là quelque part sous
les planchers la boue la mission des
hommes de la sécurité français
s'arrêtent ils vont plier bagage au
milieu de la nuit
c'est désormais leur vie qui est en jeu
ils remonteront à 350 kilomètres de là
le plus loin possible de la centrale de
fukushima une catastrophe nucléaire se
profile
pendant ce temps notre deuxième équipe
traverse un paysage tranquille et sur
cette route en lacets on en oublierait
presque que la catastrophe a eu lieu
quelques virages plus tard le squelette
d'une maison nous ramène à la réalité
la neige n'a pas tout recouvert
nous arrivons à kamaishi hier port
industriel aujourd'hui champ de ruines
sur une montagne de débris
deux militaires avec pour tout
équipement un bâton et des gants qu'est
ce que vous faites
je cherche des rescapés du tsunami
on est venu voir s'il y avait des gens à
sauver il y a eu combien de morts on
vient de commencer dans deux secteurs
dont on ne sait pas encore la ville
ressemble à une décharge dans ce magma
les objets les plus intimes ont surnagé
ce sont ses souvenirs de la vie d'avant
que les survivants recherche comme cet
homme avec son club de golf
je cherche tout ce qu'il y avait dans ma
maison
il ya eu des victimes parmi vos proches
la tante de ma mère est porté disparu
ça suffit maintenant ni larmes ni colère
cet homme n'a plus la volonté de
témoigner
nous demandons notre chemin jusqu'à
l'océan et nous des bouffons dans ce
hameau
cette jeune femme revient pour la
première fois dans son quartier
au premier coup d'oeil impossible de
retrouver l'emplacement de sa propre
maison
la vague géante n'a laissé que les
fondations
la vague est arrivée de là bas et elle
est allée jusqu'au bout
de l'autre côté j'ai eu peur j'ai cru
que j'allais mourir dans ce japon rural
tout le monde se connaissait
la maison des beaux parents étaient ici
concours jean qu il y avait 250
habitants il reste 200 personnes y
accueillir que 50 ont été emportées par
le tsunami
soudain en pleine interview la terre
tremble encore une son pouce ce n'était
qu'une petite réplique vous avez eu peur
avec le tsunami
j'ai eu peur on s'est réfugié là haut
sur la montagne à sokone fina et on a
été sauvé de là j'ai tout vu quatre ce
cas pas à nous y allons innover des
thèmes venu acheter et maintenant je
suis encore paniqués panique panique
prenez que des mots d'armes aidé c'est
ce sanctuaire perché sur les hauteurs
qui a sauvé des dizaines de villageois
cet homme lui habite la ville de l'autre
côté de la colline il voulait se rendre
compte par lui même des dégâts et le
nahd les téléphones fixes sonné dans le
vide
les portables ne passait pas donc j'ai
décidé de venir à pied a les idées
c'était un tsunami quand il en arrive
tous les mille ans si le dicton était
vrai alors le village serait pour
longtemps à l'abri d'un nouveau tsunami
mais l'avenir est moins sûr en contrebas
la jeune femme vient de retrouver sa
maison à c'est ma maison ma maison
petit miracle un collier posé sur le
béton intacte dans les ruines de
kamaichi les habitants n'ont pas fini de
errer comme des fantômes